Yves des rivières porte bien son nom ça
fait 40 ans qu'il vit son rêve de vivre
sur le bord de l'eau à Saint-Colomban
malgré les beaux souvenirs habités en
zone inondable devient de plus en plus
stressant
après les inondations de 2019 sa femme a
considéré ce prix valoir du programme de
rachat des propriétés du gouvernement et
la somoper était insuffisante elle était
tellement découragée à dire aussi c'est
tellement absurde c'est même pas le prix
de la grange il y a des enjeux que des
gens qui veulent pas déménager des zones
inondables même s'ils sont pas assurés
alors que François Legault était passage
à Gatineau une ville aussi inondée les
maires de l'Union des municipalités ont
réitéré leur demande pour l'adaptation
changement climatique je comprends que
l'argent ne pose pas dans les arbres
puis c'est la même situation chez nous
dans le monde municipal mais j'ai
entendu dans son discours soyons créatif
le Premier ministre ouvre la porte à de
nouveaux financements c'est certain que
l'impact des changements climatiques
fait qu'on est obligé de revoir les
zones inondables continuellement puis il
faut continuer d'investir mais
relocaliser les résidents n'est pas non
plus la seule solution on ne peut pas
relocaliser tout le Québec il faut
vraiment réfléchir et penser
actuellement c'est ce nouveau paradigme
vivre avec l'eau adapter les
infrastructures comme les routes mais
aussi les maisons l'idée s'ils veulent
s'ils peuvent acheter chez eux mais
c'est vraiment de pouvoir s'adapter pour
garder l'électricité garder avoir accès
à de l'eau potable etc comme c'est le
cas justement pour certains résidents de
Rigaud partir ou rester et s'adapter le
choix de la famille des rivières n'est
pas encore arrêté est-ce que vous pensez
quitter après 30 ans
moi non mon épouse oui mais comme a dit
où elle est
ici Jacoby Charbonneau Radio-Canada
saint Colomba